trois fois les jurys sinon c'est pas
très sûr mais il me semble qu'à quelque
chose qui bouge là bas au à quel endroit
exactement
ça recommence mais c'est certainement le
vent qui pousse un vieux chiffons ou
aviez morceau de papier ben oui enfin je
écoute pour te rassurer je vais aller
voir ce que c'est
ah tiens regarde c'est un vieux morceau
de papier savez j'ai mis ça
qui est il encore tu as l'air tout
effrayé
vous êtes là il arrive quelque chose
d'apprentis la vie toi aussi mais j'ai
vu quoi
il s'agit bien de monstres j'avais
promis au capitaine du port d'embarquer
pour faire une croisière comme moussa et
je ne peux plus car j'ai perdu mon
passeport
bah oui mon passeport
passeport c'est une sorte de petit libre
à qui sert de carte d'identité pour
aller dans les pays étrangers voilà qui
me tue qui aurait perdu ton ton
passeport oui enfin une page importante
du moins voilà tout on va dire on lui
parle d'un homme qui arrive dans l'île
et lui il parle de son passeport c'est
inouï comme jamais mais comment sais tu
qu'il y à un monde c'est à la fin que
nous avons trouvée françois est mort
tient à dire au fond mon passeport
ben oui c'est ce sont mes empreintes en
garde
c'est plutôt mignon
maintenant on faisait retrouver mon
passeport je peux me préparer à partie
l'érable et a passé le port
tu trouves pas que c'est triste françois
qu'est ce qui est triste julie bien que
casimir sans ouailles du lait il faut
comprendre des émirats toujours rêvé
d'embarquer sur un bateau pour visiter
les autres il et puis casimir viendra
bientôt deux ou trois semaines tout au
plus mes amis jamais présente à mousse
karim imira prêt à prendre la mer au
revoir julie
soit tranquille je suis prêt
on va définir casimir surtout obéit bien
nos commandants sur un navire le seul
maître à bord c'est le commandant
d'accord je t'écoute règle bon allez j'y
vais au revoir
j'allais oublier le principal
voilà
up
donc les émirs tu as pensé emporté un
canot de sauvetage ah non non non pas du
tout regarde c'est ma réserve
gloubiboulga a été tu as pensé à tout il
y en a au moins deux autres honneurs au
nom de deux ou trois jours pas plus
allez mes amis salut on va retenir des
bons voyage
bonnaire voire tenir bon voyage
casimir nous a envoyé je pense bien
tenir à l'air très heureux de son voyage
oui mais alors je ne comprends pas très
bien ce qu'il écrit je suis en pleine
mer il n'y a pas de tangage mais il ya
beaucoup de roulis je suis content
habituée casilli le bateau devrait
beaucoup bougé oui ils alertent
contentes ça les enfants vous savez ce
que c'est que leur oui qu'est-ce que
c'est dur oui
c'est ça vous savez tous que c'est que
le roulis le roulis c'est le mouvement
que fait un navire en mer lorsque les
vagues arrivent parallèlement à lui
comme ça alors le bateau fait comme ça
voilà et le tangage conserver ce que
c'est que le tangage
sinon
[Musique]
exactement le tangage c'est le mouvement
que celle bateau d'avant en arrière sous
l'effet des vagues qui arrive face à lui
comme ce site engage au lit eh bien je
suis sûr que casimir en air doit être
content comme tout doit pas de s'ennuyer
heureusement pour lui parce que nous
sans lui nous nous ennuyons
bowie j'espère qu'il va revenir vite
espérons lui
france soir oui aujourd'hui c'est le
retour de casimir alors je lui
confectionner une tarte et non aux
anchois à la crème de cacao et au poivre
vert julie c'est une excellente idée je
suis sûr que kazinian là serait bien
mais c'est bon ou julie nous voilà
justement qui arrivent par le chemin du
port
sam la compagnie vont la tuer bien c'est
bien
je suis vraiment content de vous
retrouver aussi accro
quelle merveille aux anchois à la crème
de cacao et au poivre vert et c'est pour
moi oui et alors ce voyage j'ai fait un
voyage formidable a donc des émirs du
n'a pas eu de mal de mer pas du tout
tout le monde le mal de mer sauf moi
avait tant mieux tout le monde à
toulouse même le commandant le commando
ou comment est ce possible mais je
t'assure que c'est vrai mais tout ça
c'est à cause de mon poids
chaque fois que j'aurai d'un côté du
bateau il penchait alors ça donne est ce
aussi un banc
un
des émirs arabes et du mal de mer qui
signe l'arrêt
j'ai une surprise pour les enfants tu va
les appeler ainsi le consensus
attendait qu'est ce que c'est vous allez
voir
voilà ça a surpris ce sont des très
beaux dessins de bateaux alors vous
allez essayer de les reconnaître vous
même d'accord c'est une bonne idée ça
regardez voici le premier
un cuirassé oui qu'est-ce que c'est un
crassier s'étant
bien c'est un très grand bateau de
guerre
qu'est ce que ça
ça s'appelle une gondole est
effectivement rien a surtout un visa il
n'ya même que ça dans les canaux
voilà nous
voilà c'est un petit bateau de pêche
comme il y en a dans l'île aux enfants
et dans tous les ports de pêche
d'ailleurs
bien plein suivant après c'est plus
difficile
c'est vraiment très fort c'est un bateau
qui s'appelle un sampan ces chinois he
et indochinois aussi
voilà
rapide alors oui alors ça c'est pas un
très grand bateau si vous en prenez un
je ne vous conseille pas d'aller en
pleine mer pas trop loin a bâti ce
serait dangereux puis ça fait mal jean
louis
sagot casimir et ignoble mais non c'est
ni un vaisseau ni un bateau ni un avis à
aa je passe un savon aux bateaux annonce
est un papa écoute moi alors monsieur du
sna m'a toujours dit quand les chameaux
et un les besson du désert